hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching gremlins 2 I'm
dressed up as the female gremlin it's a
little it's a little distracting
I really enjoyed the first gremlins in a
way that was like it had cool practicals
it was fun enough I loved it as a
Christmas film I can't believe that
there was a second one made
that's so weird to me and I've heard
that the director didn't want it made
and didn't want to make it but everyone
was like we'll just give you any amount
of money you want cuz it was such a
giant success and just make whatever and
so he did apparently is what I've heard
and I'm pretty excited about it cuz that
sounds to me that sounds like it's gonna
be a ridiculous mess which same meet you
this is for black nerd this is bu Andre
[Music]
what what was that I'm so full this time
would kick Oh somebody I used to meet so
many things to talk about I'm so excited
that was such a weird that was funnier
who's more fun crazy budget it was I
loved it I liked this a lot more than I
liked the first and I enjoyed the first
but Oh buddy so we get a little
backstory with mr. wings shop and some
big business tycoon is trying to buy his
shop so it can go in a giant mall and he
doesn't want to sell it but it's mostly
just a way for you to see what's been
going on and see gizmo and gizmos
watching Rambo which is adorable add
that to list of my movies that I still
need to watch okay then mr. wing dies
and the mall construction has started
that was this easy the billion cake in
the first movie have moved to New York
and are struggling to make it by uh
young love brought together by
terrorizing small little mystical
creatures tales Melanie has a job as an
architect pretty much like designing the
building for the new mall and Kate is a
tour guide which I don't know why that's
funny to me but I also just really loved
the little hats of the tour guides where
I want one then you're introduced to the
scientists who took gizmo so this guy
mr. clamp wants to make a mom he already
has a giant business center and in the
business center is where the scientists
have their office you meet the head
scientist played by Christopher Lee and
it's so funny he's great he's such a
good character in this and I want to say
he's my favorite but there's some it's a
couple really great characters of this
movie oh is this my malaria its rabies
powers so I love Christopher Lee I love
all of the scientists I however do not
like Billy's boss I hate her accent I
hate the character I don't I don't like
it I don't like her at all
no she flirts a lot with Billy and it
gets him in trouble later with Kate and
that's it's a lot she's a lot that's
workplace harassment
Billy you go you run for the hills Billy
but she invites you to dinner to further
their careers and she says yes to
further his career not to flirt Billy is
not like that he does not play those
games and he leaves gizmo who he rescued
from the science offices earlier a lot
is already he leaves gizmo in his office
for Kate to pick up later but of course
we all know what's gonna happen gizmo
gets wet in the office and creates the
new batch of gremlins to the new batch a
new batch I will say the the new puppets
that they use in this are very animated
more so and more distinct characters
than the last
it's the last batch the old batch so
while it dinner the redheaded boss
kisses Billy on the side of the mouth
and then like claws his penis with her
foot which is an aggressive move that's
a Power Move he's not having any of it
he goes home he doesn't wipe the
lipstick off and Kate sees it and she
doesn't say anything she's like well we
have probably Darnell do that later blah
blah and I'm like oh that's not how I
would have handled that I would have
been like okay cool well your apartments
a mess because I accidentally didn't
take gizmo home I took one of the new
batch so good luck with that let me take
your credit card go to Greece
what do I want to go
so they go back to find gizmo and it's a
mess everything after this is just it's
just like an hour of chaos Billy is just
like he's also just he's such a mess he
goes to jail real quick he's not the
best hero but he's also the worst year
so the cocoon things from the first of
course are in this and the new batch
hatch that's really fun to say that's as
fun as you think it is to say the new
batch hatch the thing that I really
loved about this film is there's a lot
of random comedy and over the
loudspeakers of the building that I
really really really loved the last
figure goes on for one line it says will
the owner of the car with the license
plate g6 7 z1 2 please remove your
vehicle from the clamp parking lot it's
old and ugly there's one point where
everything's going wrong and people are
trying to get on the building and it's
just like chaos and a mess and the
loudspeaker goes on and goes we are now
experiencing technical difficulties
please try not to notice another
character that I loved I thought that
they were gonna portray him as like a
really bad guy cuz he wanted to buy mr.
wings shop and he of them eventually
just took it over was mr. clamp he was
like kind of at the beginning portrayed
as this big bad business guy who doesn't
care about anything but I loved him he's
a great character he shreds one of the
gremlins in a shredder it's great at the
end he gives everyone great jobs he's
always just like so excited and happy I
love mr. Quayle then you get the sketch
with the movie police and the movie
polices it is reviewing the first
gremlins it also just screams a sketch
that somebody who didn't want to make
this one who was just like yeah that
last one was shit I loved it I had a
blast with this kind of all I want to do
I'm gonna do this new one fine let's
write this sketch it like it felt like
that I loved it I wrote oh my god why is
all open here oh my god amazing
WTF why yeah
good work a camera I am a camera follow
me on Instagram then the female gremlin
comes in and Wow
okay again follow me on Instagram all
right I just wrote they play some Slayer
and they show the gremlins mutating even
worse which I really loved the
creativity with that but despite or
Emlyn is really cool like somebody
cosplay that's five spider gremlin right
now so please like please and then you
get Rambo gizmo which I love I didn't
love 15 it's adorable I'm all about his
little murder spree this little fluff
okay we that Lincoln moment with case I
didn't understand that in the least bit
she's like I don't like Lincoln because
this one time in a park there was this
old man and it was weird what was that
about and everyone was like don't not
right now okay like maybe she used to
talk they have a whole plan to take down
the gremlins it doesn't work so they
electrocuted gremlins with one of the
gremlins somehow that's where we've
gotten to I wrote I love the boss I love
the resolve and even the female gremlin
finds happiness masterpiece Bravo wow it
was fun it was really fun I really
enjoyed watching this I would put this
on with friends like drinking with buds
like I would I would put it on again
you'll appreciate how skilled the
gremlins are at arranging a musical show
with props and costumes I was and I
loved the musical number hey Tamara what
else do you want out of a gremlins film
you saw the first one it was what else
what do you want in there I don't know
maybe like a really fantastic musical
number
don't you worry we got you bet you're
going to want to do a cosplay of the
female gremlin
it's a cosplay that's how you look
you won't hate it and that is all I can
predict at the moment safe I like that
though you'll be sad that it's not as
scary by God you will still love it
because it's way funnier I love scary
movies I didn't find me the first ones
scary at all it was just like a mildly
like on the verge of being scary without
that much comedy this one was like still
mildly not scary but like so funny that
I've done it a lot more enjoyable you
will believe that it is one of the few
sequels that greatly suppresses the
original yes I had such a good time with
this woman I always love a great
Tambor's never seen episode where I
could dress up so I saw the female
gremlin I was like oh hell yeah oh and
thank you so much for watching I had a
blast with this one see you guys soon
I have so much makeup on
[Music]
[Applause]
you